madame la ministre merci d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation donc nous poursuivons
nos travaux nous les avons commencé à
l'instant avec l'audition de Monsieur
François de Rugy et nous les poursuivons
avec votre audition madame la ministre
parmi les nombreuses importantes
fonctions que vous avez exercées je veux
simplement rappeler pour ce qui concerne
notre commission d'enquête que vous avez
été par deux fois à 20 ans d'écart en
charge des sujets environnementaux au
gouvernement la première fois comme
ministre chargé de l'environnement de
1992 à 1993 puis comme ministre de
l'environnement de l'énergie et de la
mer chargé des Relations internationales
sur le climat de 2014 à 2017
c'est surtout cette dernière période qui
va retenir notre attention même s'il
sera certainement intéressant de
comprendre avec vous comment le sujet de
la rénovation énergétique a pu mûrir
dans le pays dans le temps alors qu'un
pays par exemple comme la Suède avait
infléchi fortement sa politique dès le
choc pétrolier ce qui n'a pas été le cas
dans notre pays mais pour revenir à la
période 2014-2017 elle est marquée par
deux événements importants l'accord de
Paris sur le climat en 2015 qui est un
peu la toile de fond et pour le concret
de la rénovation énergétique la loi de
transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte du 17 août 2015 que
vous avez porté les exigences en matière
de sobriété énergétique imposée par
l'accord de Paris et inscrit dans la
stratégie nationale bas carbone exige
une rénovation profonde du bâtiment en
France
c'était l'objectif de la loi pour la
croissance verte qui apparaît
aujourd'hui comme celle qui a fixé le
cadre et les principaux objectifs des
politiques menées en la manière à la
manière les lois énergiques climat de
2019 est plus récemment la loi climat
est résilience de 2021 venant la profond
dire mais aussi souvent reporter
certains objectifs ces objectifs les
plus marquants et structurants étaient
certainement la mise aux normes bâtiment
basse consommation du parc d'ici 2050 la
réalisation de 500 000 rénovations de
logements par an dont la moitié
occupée par des ménages modestes la
suppression des passoires thermiques F
et G d'ici 2025 et la réduction de la
précarité énergétique de 15% d'ici 2020
pourtant aujourd'hui le bâtiment demeure
un secteur particulièrement énergivore
qui représente 43% de la consommation
les énergies en France et génère 23% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
français le logement représente les deux
tiers des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre la rénovation énergétique reste
également une question sociale puisque
20% des Français sont considérés en
situation de précarité énergétique selon
l'Observatoire de la précarité
énergétique en 2021 il en est de même de
l'objectif des 500 000 logements rénovés
par an puisque bien souvent ces travaux
se résument à un seul geste alors qu'il
faudrait conduire une rénovation globale
madame la ministre je souhaite que vous
puissiez nous éclairer sur le bilan que
vous tirez de votre expérience que vous
puissiez nous dire quels sont vos motifs
de satisfaction et vous regrets vous
liez-vous aller plus loin et si la
réponse est positive qu'est-ce qui vous
en a empêché
je voudrais également vous inviter avec
le recul et la hauteur de vue qui sont
les vôtres à nous donner votre analyse
des raisons pour lesquelles les
objectifs affichés n'ont pas été
atteints quel jugement portez-vous sur
la politique qui a été menée en manière
en matière de rénovation énergétique
depuis maintenant un peu plus de 5 ans
voilà donc avant de laisser la parole
bien sûr à notre rapporteur et de vous
laisser d'abord un propos introductif
d'environ une quinzaine de minutes il me
revient de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat et
qu'elle fera l'objet d'un compte rendu
publié je dois également vous rappeler
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission d'enquête serait passible des
peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à euros d'amende je vous
invite donc madame la ministre a prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité et à lever la main droite et à
dire je le jure
alors sans plus tarder je vous laisse la
parole pour environ 15 minutes de propos
introductif et ensuite monsieur le
rapporteur et nos collègues pourront
vous poser un certain nombre de
questions complémentaires
vous sur cette importance sujet que la
rénovation et la performance énergétique
des bâtiments
c'est un sujet qui m'a toujours
passionné qui m'a toujours mobilisé et
quand la première chose parce que vous
avez l'expérience du des actions locales
et quand je suis arrivé dans ce
ministère j'avais déjà tenté parfois
avec succès d'ailleurs je me dis
modestement à faire de ma région la
région de l'excellence environnementale
et une des premières décisions que j'ai
prise en 2004 en arrivant c'est de
construire le premier lycée c'est un
lycée professionnel à côté de Poitiers
le premier lycée a énergie positive
d'ailleurs appelé lycée Kyoto
qu'est-ce que ce que le Japon vient
faire là et comme je pense que toutes
les opportunités sont bonnes à prendre
pour apprendre des choses j'avais
expliqué donc c'était le nom du premier
protocole climat le protocole de Kyoto
donc ce lycée a été construit à la fois
avec les énergies renouvelables
récupération d'eau de pluie performances
énergétique isolation etc et quand je
suis donc arrivé
dans ce ministère avec cette
responsabilité là je vais déjà
développer et vu un certain nombre de
choses sur la fois les opportunités
opérationnelles et sur les freins aussi
à la rénovation énergétique en
particulier sur le logement social je me
souviens
ça doit être pareil sur vos territoires
à l'époque quand il y avait des
logements sociaux ont supprimé les
cheminées dans le milieu rural et moi
qui venais qui est passé ma vie dans mon
enfance en milieu rural dans les Vosges
on se chauffe et aux bois les chambres
étaient pas chauffées donc on apprenait
les économies d'énergie ça paraît
relever du siècle dernier mais c'est
vrai que du coup j'avais dit mais non le
joint sociaux mais non vous laissez les
les
cheminées alors on me dit maintenant les
gens vont déclencher les vont déclencher
les feux de cheminée mais non on est en
milieu rural les gens savent
parfaitement se chauffer au bois ça fait
des générations qu'on le fait et donc ça
m'a fait plaisir après en revenant au
ministère de relancer la filière bois de
chauffage et la cogénération au parce
que c'est vraiment des filières
formidables en France on a un potentiel
forestier très très important ça c'est
pour vous donner un petit peu le
l'ambiance et ensuite donc j'ai fait
voter la loi de transition énergétique
que j'ai voulu exemplaire avant la cop21
ce que l'idée de se dépêcher pour la loi
transition énergétique de du mois d'août
2015 c'était dire bon bah la France
accueille la COP 21 il faut vraiment
qu'on soit exemplaire et qu'on anticipe
les contraintes de la COP 21 dans notre
propre stratégie nationale et dans notre
stratégie bas carbone donc peut-être en
deux mots pour voir comment est-ce que
le titre sur les bâtiments s'insèrent
dans cette loi il y avait trois
objectifs que j'avais à signal à la loi
de sur la croissance verte c'était
lutter bien sûr contre le réchauffement
climatique c'était ensuite réduire la
facture énergétique
qui est de 70 milliards de déficits de
la balance commerciale à ce moment-là et
c'était développé des filières de
compétitivité et d'innovation dans ce
domaine avec deux outils opérationnel
parce que j'ai toujours pensé que le
local le Global c'est-à-dire
l'international comme 21 le National les
stratégies nationales et le local les
territoires et les citoyens doivent tous
tirer dans la même direction si on veut
des résultats et dans cette loi donc
j'ai créé les territoires énergies
positifs avec en particulier parce que
c'était la première préoccupation des
élus c'est l'isolation des bâtiments
municipaux en particulier pour faire des
économies d'énergie d'une part et puis
le crédit d'impôt de transition
énergétique qui permettait aux
particuliers sans condition de
ressources parce que j'estimais qu'on
était dans une transition énergétique et
que il fallait permettre à tout le monde
de se remettre à niveau sur l'isolation
des logements le crédit d'impôt donc je
dis bien le crédit d'impôt c'est à dire
que les gens qui n'étaient pas
imposables avaient donc ce crédit qui
leur était apporté pour pouvoir faire
les travaux parce qu'on disait quand on
vous dit il y a pas de conditions de
revenus non et donc ceux qui payent pas
d'impôts bénéficie pas non c'était pas
une déduction fiscale c'est un crédit
d'impôt donc il recevait le versement de
l'équivalent de de l'investissement donc
c'était 8000 euros par personne seul et
15000 euros pour un couple 16000 euros
pour un couple de déduction fiscale
davantage fisc davantage fiscal pour les
travaux de d'énergie
d'efficacité énergétique
et Madame là Président vous avez raison
de dire que la performance énergétique
ça concerne les bâtis les bâtiments ils
avaient dit les deux tiers c'était avant
les transports on l'oublie parce que le
transport on voit l'essence mais non
c'est bien le bâtiment qui consomme le
plus d'énergie avant les transports et
même avant l'industrie donc c'est
considérable en fait donc le potentiel
il est considérable et ce qui est
intéressant dans cette filière c'est
comme je viens de le dire c'est qu'il y
a la fois des décisions individuelles
des décisions municipales des décisions
départementales des décisions régionales
des décisions nationales des décisions
de l'industrie aussi parce qu'il y a des
bâtiments industriels il y a des
bâtiments commerciaux il y a des
aéroports qui devraient toutes
uniquement il devrait y avoir déjà des
centrales solaires sur tous les
aéroports français sans parler de la
récupération d'eau pluie qui pourrait
laver les avions au lieu d'utiliser
l'eau potable enfin bon un peu trop lent
mais tout ça avait été dit pendant les
débats de et ça c'est vraiment
consensuel parce que tout le monde quel
que soit vous voyez les partis
politiques les groupes politiques ça
c'est vraiment des sujets je me souviens
dans la loi de transition énergétique et
en passionné tout le monde est vraiment
les les votes étaient acquis à
l'unanimité
donc ensuite
l'autre objectif de la loi c'était de ne
pas opposer les énergies les unes aux
autres donc je passe sur la polémique
sur l'énergie nucléaire parce que ça
concerne pas le bâtiment et puis surtout
donc les faire des énergies propres des
énergies sûr et des énergies les moins
chères possible donc c'est dans ce
cadre-là finalement que
se situe la problématique d'économie
d'énergie de performance énergétique et
le grand chantier du bâtiment qui permet
de faire baisser les factures pour les
gens de créer des emplois dans le
bâtiment
d'économiser l'énergie au niveau
national
il y a que du c'est que du plus c'est
que du positif c'est que du
gagnant-gagnant pour tout le monde donc
vous avez bien déjà commencé à détailler
tous les outils que j'avais mis dans la
loi d'abord premièrement des nouvelles
règles qui rendent des marchés et
réduisant les coûts donc avec les
bâtiments énergies positifs et afin
faibles empreinte carbone et mon idée
alors c'est trop audacieux donc c'était
dire tous les nouveaux bâtiments vous
devrez être bâtiment énergie positive ça
me semblait tellement évident moi
j'avais vu que c'était possible j'en
avais fait mais la filière du bâtiment
résistait quand même beaucoup et j'ai
pas compris pourquoi parce que je les
faisais venir finir du bâtiment j'y mets
c'est votre intérêt vous allez créer des
emplois des activités mais il y avait
quand même une grande inertie et
d'ailleurs ils ont fait supprimer le
l'individualisation des frais de
chauffage ils ont fait supprimer plein
de choses et il y avait la pression du
bâtiment et je leur ai expliqué mais
c'est dans votre intérêt puisque vous
allez pouvoir développer même des
savoir-faire des nouveaux matériaux
faire des économies même dans la
construction conquérir des marchés
international si on est les meilleurs
sur ce secteur vous allez vous déployer
vous développer etc il y avait quand
même beaucoup de réticences
et moi mon idéal pour répondre à la
question que vous avez posé qu'est-ce
que je regrette c'est que tous les
nouveaux bâtiments il est pas trop tard
soit tous à énergie positive qu'est-ce
que c'est un bâtiment énergie positif
même moi j'avais donné au territoire et
il y en a quelques-uns qui sont déjà
construits notamment des logements c'est
un bâtiment qui produit au moins autant
d'énergie qu'il n'en consomme
quand même extraordinaire donc vous avez
vous arrivez dans ces bâtiments la
facture des gens c'est 3 euros 4 euros
par mois parce que le bâtiment produit
autant d'énergie qu'il en consomme alors
ça veut dire des panneaux solaires sur
le toit quand c'est possible ça veut
dire la récupération de la chaleur ça
veut dire des performances énergétiques
exceptionnelles et surtout des
récupérations de chaleur le long des
circuits on maîtrise les technologies
donc ça ça pourrait être répandu c'est à
dire quand vous allez dans la salle de
chaudière la récupération de chaleur
elle est pas perdue elle est récupérée
et il y a même des bâtiments où on
récupère la chaleur dans les cuisines
quand vous faites votre cuisine il y a
de la chaleur cette chaleur est
récupérée et recycler pour qu'il n'y ait
zéro perdition de chaleur donc c'est
aussi des des technologies à développer
et qui qui sont maîtrisés
et surtout l'isolation des toitures des
portes des fenêtres et des façades c'est
des technologies qu'on maîtrise et donc
il est parfaitement possible de
construire des bâtiments à énergie
positives aujourd'hui ensuite j'avais
mis l'obligation de l'isolation quand il
y a des travaux de ravalement
et l'argument qu'utilisé à ce moment-là
ce qui résistait c'était non mais quand
il y a en Alsace quand il y a des des
façades pardon vous êtes
moi je suis non j'étais en Normandie
aussi donc quand il y a des
ou du bois etc comme on va faire
il peut y avoir des exceptions on va pas
annuler un plan national et pour qui on
peut faire des exceptions effectivement
il y a les bateaux des bâtiments classés
on va pas coller des
l'isolation extérieure sur les bâtiments
classés etc mais je me souviens de ça
parce que ça avait été utilisé par les
filières bâtiment pour dire non mais
faut pas c'est trop tôt c'est trop vite
etc dit non ce qui coûte cher c'est les
échafaudages et je vois que ça a pas été
rétabli ces échafaudages donc autant en
profiter et plus on en fera moi ça
coûtera cher parce que plus on mettra au
point des matériaux intéressants sur y
compris des matériaux venant de
l'agriculture puisque l'agriculture
française a des tout premier potentiels
en matière de production de biomasse y
compris de matériaux d'isolation comme
le chanvre par exemple j'avais développé
aussi le chanvre dans ma région parce
que c'est un des un des matériaux les
plus isolants en termes de d'efficacité
énergétique donc ça je trouve que
c'était très important il faudrait
vraiment remettre ça bon malheureusement
depuis le coup des travaux a augmenté
vous voyez donc ça veut bien dire qu'on
avait raison en 2015 à poser ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça coûte plus cher de
faire des ravalement donc les gens
encore moins les moyens de faire les
deux c'est ça qui est dommage ensuite
les compteurs individuels de frais de
chauffage quelle bataille ça a été et
j'avais vu dans plusieurs rapports
parlementaires notamment dans les pays
voisins que quand vous avez un logement
collectif le jour où vous mettez des
calculs individuels de frais de
chauffage je vous jure que c'est vrai la
consommation diminue de 70%
parce que pourquoi parce que les gens
qui sortent de chez eux ils ferment le
radiateur
ils partent en vacances il ferme le
radiateur et quand c'est collectifs s'il
voit pas l'impact sur leur facture bon
il ferme pas le radiateur je ne vois pas
pourquoi il y a des individuels pour
l'eau et pas des compteurs individuels
de frais de chauffage c'est obligation a
été supprimée parce que aussi il y a eu
la pression des syndics de gestion c'est
à dire l'économise économiser l'énergie
c'est du voilà c'est c'est des
prestations en moins c'est c'est des
circles économiques qui qui changent et
pourtant c'est extrêmement efficace
que de calculer individuellement les
frais de chauffage et c'est beaucoup
plus juste alors pour être exact aussi
il y a une grande et une grande
résistance des offices HLM
alors ça aussi ça me scandalisé je dis
mais vous devriez être les premiers à
réclamer l'individualisation des frais
de chauffage parce que ça va diminuer
collectivement la facture des gens alors
l'autre gros argument qui était c'était
dire oui mais ceux qui sont au
rez-de-chaussée et ceux qui sont en
dernière étage vont avoir plus de
chauffage que ceux qui sont dans le
sandwich au milieu de là où c'est
chauffé au-dessus c'est pas grave on
fait une paire équation que on peut très
bien
péricouer pour 10% de la facture pour
tenir compte de cette configuration et
puis après ceux qui sont en haut ils ont
une plus belle vue aussi enfin je veux
dire on s'arrête par mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a ce petit point là qui fait que
dans le collectif en tout cas il n'y a
pas de problème sans solution je pense
que ce problème là il peut être
également résolu
ensuite il y a un bonus de
constructibilité pour les constructions
exemplaires du point de vue énergétique
et environnemental alors ça je sais pas
si ça a été maintenu en tout cas c'était
très efficace parce que par exemple pour
les immeubles en bois
construction bois comme l'épaisseur est
plus importantes les promoteurs nous
disaient les constructeurs nous disaient
mais non vous allez nous faire perdre en
mètre carré habitable puisque si on fait
de l'isolation les murs sont plus épais
les planchers sont plus épais donc on va
perdre en hauteur sous plafond etc et à
ce moment j'avais dit ceux qui sont
hautes performance environnementale et
notamment les constructions bois parce
que là aussi il perdait un demi étage
dans un construction bois vous aurez un
bonus de mètres carrés et de
constructibilité pour tenir compte de la
contrainte voilà du différentiel donc ça
c'était aussi important de reconnaître
cette préoccupation là
ensuite il y a eu le soutien aux
particuliers donc pour financer la
rénovation énergétique de leur logement
avec
la réforme de l'écho-préatoséro le
crédit d'impôt de transition énergétique
et la possibilité de cumuler les deux
comment c'était pas cumulable moi j'ai
autorisé le cumul des deux aujourd'hui
il y a la prime rénale mais je sais pas
si vous avez curiosité de regarder les
dossiers
la primorenave c'est un dossier de 10
pages le crédit d'impôt il y avait trois
cases à cocher dans votre déclaration
d'impôts
et donc j'avais simplifié la procédure
parce que c'est vrai que le ministère
des Finances ils ont beaucoup de parents
pour inventer des déductions fiscales
inapplicables c'était très très
compliqué il y avait très peu de
bénéficiaires du dispositif antérieur
parce que il fallait faire plus
obligatoirement plusieurs travaux vous
étiez obligés d'isoler par exemple les
combles et les fenêtres
mais vous pouviez pas avoir le crédit
d'impôt si vous n'isoliez par exemple
que vos fenêtres
et à ce moment j'avais dit mais les gens
ils ont parfois forcément les moyens de
faire tout tout de suite donc il faut
laisser faire les travaux voyez sur deux
ans ou sur trois ans pour pouvoir étaler
le coût des travaux et les
investissements nécessaires et donc
c'était très très simple crédit d'impôt
bien vous faisiez les travaux que vous
vouliez vous avez votre déduction
fiscale
et c'est extraordinaire et donc dans la
foulée pour que les gens se fassent pas
rouler quand même par des mauvais
artisans on avait créé le
comment dirais le conventionnement c'est
les artisans devaient prouver leur
compétences et les prix qui pratiquaient
pour éviter vous voyez l'effet de
cliquer c'est à dire vous donner un
crédit d'impôt pouf les prix augmentent
puis leur disant vous dire bah non vous
allez avoir le crédit d'impôt donc je
peux augmenter les prix donc on avait
surveillé tous protocole et surtout on
avait une vie fait la liste des artisans
qui étaient homologués pour faire mes
travaux d'économie d'énergie le jour où
le crédit d'impôt a été supprimé mais
c'était dramatique c'est à dire que les
artisans et fait un effort pour se
former pour former leur salarié pour
recruter ce que ça avait l'échantillon
avait explosé dans le domaine notamment
l'isolation des fenêtres
et des portes et d'isolation des des
combles c'était les trois sujets qui
entraînaient des économies d'énergie
alors l'isolation des murs c'était un
peu plus cher mais je pense que les gens
l'auraient si c'était ça avait été
maintenu vous voyez les gens l'auraient
fait des années suivantes en fait
l'isolation par l'extérieur ou par
l'intérieur c'est quand il y avait des
boiseries
voilà et donc ça s'est arrêté et je
pense que dans le secteur j'ai pas été
10000 emplois qui ont dû être supprimés
dans le secteur des isolation des
fenêtres voilà ça a été des une
d'isolation et je pense ça c'est une
réflexion globale il faut de la
continuité dans ces domaines pour les
entreprises pour ça c'est insupportable
ça bouge tout le temps les dossiers
bougent les noms des dossiers bougent il
faut du temps vous voyez pour une
entreprise donc là ils ont eu
2016-2017 2018 ça c'est effondré et
alors que je pense qu'on aurait continué
les thèmes CV et le crédit d'impôts
mais je pense qu'on aurait peut-être
aujourd'hui 50% de des bâtiments isolés
d'abord tous les bâtiments publics ont
été faits parce que tous les maires
faisaient leurs écoles leur mairie les
salles polyvalentes
les départements faisaient les
collèges je pense que tout ça aura été
fait avec le
l'étape CV donc j'avais mis 750 millions
d'euros il va y avoir à nouveau 750
millions normalement il devait y avoir
un milliard et demi il y a eu 750
millions d'euros qui ont été distribués
au collectivités locales et ça devait
continuer les années suivantes et puis
ça aussi
ça s'est arrêté et comme moi j'avais
l'expérience en tant qu'élud local de
région des complexités des subventions
d'État j'avais archi mais simplifié à
tel point qu'il y a eu un rapport de la
Cour des comptes dans un premier acné
etc régulier parce que j'avais fait des
argumentaires mais la tracasserie vous
connaissez ça d'aller chercher les
cofinancements alors l'état donne 10% au
Conseil Général conseiller régional à la
Caisse des Dépôts je lui ai dit non sur
la loi de transition énergétique il faut
que ça aille vite et en fait en financer
à 100% les opérations dans les
territoires énergies positives donc il
nouvelles opérations qui qui se sont
développées et ça aussi ça aurait dû
être
poursuivi après la mise en place de
sociétés de tiers financement je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez de ça c'était
original c'était une dérogation monopole
bancaire pour avancer au particulier qui
engageaient travaux de rénovation
énergétique
un ces sociétés de tiers financement et
la Banque européenne d'investissement
j'étais allé voir pour financer cette
opération avait financé auteur de 400
millions d'euros et c'est une idée qui
m'avait été donnée par des collectivités
locales ça parce que les départements en
particulier qui avaient du mal aussi à
emprunter même si la Caisse des Dépôts
faisait des prêts c'est sur le terrain
que j'avais eu trouvé cette idée de
société de tiers financement et ça
c'était formidable parce que du coup il
y avait il y avait le prix des travaux
mais il y avait pas en plus vous voyez
le prix de l'emprunt pour les gens et je
les collectivités locales aussi ont pu y
accéder
le point suivant c'est des appels à
projet pour des réalisations
urbaines innovantes et exemplaires donc
on avait mis en place j'ai mis en place
16 démonstrateurs industriels pour la
ville durable qui avait été désigné le
23 décembre 2015 donc en application la
loi transition énergétique ça m'a permis
de valoriser ça à la cop21 et c'est
démonstrateurs donc il y avait 16
démonstrateurs industriels qui étaient
remontées avec un appel à projet et des
opérations donc urbaine que qui du coup
pouvait obtenir des financements
complémentaires
voilà après il y a le problème des
transports mais bon c'est d'autres
sujets mais voilà l'essentiel mais
d'ailleurs que vous avez parfaitement
pardon j'étais peut-être un peu longue
résumé tout à l'heure merci madame la
ministre je vais y laisser la parole à
Monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
madame la ministre déjà pour cette état
des lieux en tout cas sur sur ce qui a
pu ce que vous avez pu mettre en mettre
en oeuvre et notamment à travers
le texte sur la transition énergétique
pour la pour la croissance verte vous
avez fait un état d'élus assez précis et
c'est vrai que ce texte déjà en 2015 on
se fait se fixer des objectifs assez
ambitieux même très ambitieux sur 500
000 logements 500 000 logements rénovés
la suppression des passoires thermiques
et c'est vrai qu'on est pour le coup
aujourd'hui loin loin du compte donc je
voulais déjà savoir si selon vous
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui a péché quoi
alors vous avez vous en avez un petit
peu un petit peu dit mais est-ce que
c'est justement la suppression de
certaines mesures dont vous avez évoqué
est-ce que c'est un manque de
financement et notamment c'est vrai que
ça m'intéresserait de savoir à la fois
vous en tant que mini sur les arbitrages
en termes de financement est-ce que
forcément ils ont financement est
importante mais du coup est-ce que ça
aurait permis d'aller beaucoup plus vite
enfin voilà et d'avoir un petit peu
votre vision par rapport à au fait que
justement on n'a pas atteint nos
objectifs qu'on en est encore encore
assez loin j'avais une question aussi
peut-être sur la question que vous avez
beaucoup appuyé sur la question des
territoires et de l'aspect local et
c'est vrai que moi je trouve qui avait
été intéressant qui avait été mis en
place vous en avez parlé à travers tes
postes FCV territoires énergies positive
et le fait que effectivement il y ait
des financements local qui soit mise en
place et notamment à travers cette
période la mise en place de de
plateforme de rénovation thermique qui
ont et qui ont été mis en place sur les
sur les territoires et c'est vrai que de
mon regard en tout cas des délu local ce
que j'ai pu voir c'est que ces
plateformes quand elles étaient en place
et notamment sur des secteurs plutôt
plutôt rural mais on a les Alecs sur des
sur des zones beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus denses étaient quand même un
système qui fonctionne
qui fonctionne toujours d'ailleurs mais
qui fonctionne plutôt bien avec
notamment la proximité un accompagnement
c'est vrai collègue François de Rugy
tout à l'heure était moins enthousiaste
sur cette question là puisque l'exemple
qui donnait en disant que oui ça a
fonctionné mais c'est très petit à une
échelle sauf que l'exemple qu'il a donné
sans logement pour 50
000 pour un territoire de 50000
habitants mine de rien si on le rapporte
à la à l'échelle du pays c'est pas si
mal fait en tout cas les a pas atteints
en termes de rénovation globale et de
Bâtiment Basse Consommation donc je
trouvais en tout cas que c'est un
dispositif qui était intéressant et dont
je voulais avoir votre votre avis et sur
peut-être la poursuite de ça et sur le
fait que on s'aperçoit que ces
plateformes de rénovation sont en
souvent en difficulté sur les
territoires par manque de financement
d'accompagnement etc
donc voilà si vous pouviez peut-être
nous dire quelques mots là-dessus et
puis sur l'évolution donc vous avez
parlé du cite et l'évolution vers ma
prime ma prime rénov
voilà voir vous avez aussi également
esquisser mais un petit peu votre votre
avis sur sur cet aspect sur cet aspect
là j'ai compris l'intérêt effectivement
du crédit du crédit d'impôt
qu'avait quand même quelques
problématiques aussi par rapport à il y
a eu quand même pas mal de sujets à la
fois de fraude des phénomènes enfin en
tout cas il y a eu quand même quelques
quelques
problématiques par rapport à au cite
mais bon prime rénov on s'aperçoit qu'on
a un peu un peu également les mêmes
dérives donc à voir aussi votre avis
là-dessus et puis peut-être terminé
aussi parce que vous en avez aussi un
petit peu parlé peut-être sur les
exemples à l'étranger si justement quand
vous avez travaillé sur la question
est-ce que vous étiez à la fois inspiré
est-ce que vous avez des exemples à
l'étranger qui pourraient justement en
termes de d'efficacité en terme de
politique publique qui ont été mis en
place voilà merci
s'il vous plaît
merci de d'évoquer effectivement les
plateformes de rénovation qui ont été
mises en place avec des partenariats
très intéressants et là aussi très libre
en fonction des collectivités
territoriales et notamment partenariat
avec l'ADEME donc ce qui était très ce
qui était très intéressant dans ces
plateformes d'ailleurs tous les
territoires énergies positifs mettez en
place des plateformes c'est-à-dire que
les gens ils sont un peu perdus quand
ils se disent il faut faire des travaux
à qui on s'adresse comment ça se passe
et l'intérêt des plateformes c'est que
elles avaient je pense que c'est
toujours le cas d'ailleurs
une banque de données c'est par exemple
vous voulez mettre une chaudière bois
dans un immeuble collectif j'avais fait
en sorte qu'ils aient des crédits pour
mettre en place des plaques des banques
de données vous tapez le chauffage bois
et vous avez les réalisations qui ont
été homologuées etc et donc vous pouvez
aller visiter des réalisations que vous
voulez réaliser dans votre commune dans
votre canton dans votre territoire et ça
c'est irremplaçable parce que
je veux dire territoire par territoire
il y a pas forcément la ressource
industrielle ou artisanale et en
revanche dès que vous allez voir des
choses faites beaucoup d'ailleurs par
exemple de l'agriculteurs ce sont des
placés sur les méthaniseurs parce qu'ils
avaient envie d'aller voir là où ça
marchait est-ce que ça correspondait à
leur potentiel et cetera et c'est vrai
aussi donc pour les bâtiments et les et
les opérations d'innovation
d'isolation thermique des bâtiments donc
ça je crois que c'est effectivement très
important
votre deuxième question c'est sur les 2e
question c'est sur oui qu'est-ce qu'il y
a raté c'est l'arrêt
c'est tellement difficile vous savez
dans des arbitrages interministériels
c'était des combats d'obtenir un crédit
d'impôt je sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte par rapport au ministère des
Finances c'est inimaginable d'obtenir un
crédit d'impôt moi comment je faisais
jimiler à COP 21 comme 21 il faut qu'on
soit à la hauteur de la COP 21 il faut
faire des choses extra exceptionnelles
parce que c'est la cop21 c'est comme ça
que j'arrive à arracher les arbitrages
mais c'était pas c'était pas évident
donc voir ensuite au delà des clivages
politiques d'ailleurs que ça s'arrête
c'est désolant parce que vous disiez
tellement difficile le temps que les
gens se l'approprient que ça soit connu
qu'on envoie les instructions que les
artisans et les entreprises du bâtiment
s'y habitue que les gens parce qu'il y a
des gens aussi beaucoup de gens qui
avaient programmé des travaux qui PAF
ça s'est arrêté du jour au lendemain
donc c'est il y a eu un potentiel de
développement économique même qui a été
qui a été perdue et sur l'étape CV donc
c'est pareil c'est merveilleux quand
vous regardez les thèmes CV il y a
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours les inventaire
de tout ce qui a été fait c'est un peu
continué mais brutalement il y avait ce
soutien financier et c'était formidable
parce que on voyait tous les mers les
prisons de communauté de communes venir
au ministère ont projeté ce qu'ils
avaient réalisé sur leur territoire mais
c'était merveilleux Xavier la diversité
française avec la diversité des
ressources locales des mères et des élus
qui connaissaient mais rien à l'écologie
et qui tout d'un coup se passionner sur
ces sujets et puis après il se passionné
pour la biodiversité et puis après il se
passionnait sur les expériences
éducatives dans leurs écoles
c'est très très vertueux l'environnement
ça tire tout le monde vers le haut donc
c'est formidable et les gens apprenaient
ils réalisaient c'était très très
gratifiant en plus pour les élus et moi
j'apportais l'argent
en ayant essayé normalement on va lui
promis un milliard et demi
je vais calculer ça j'ai eu un milliard
et demi il y a du potentiel etc donc la
première enveloppe ça a été 750 millions
et quand je suis parti devait y avoir
750 millions et c'est et ça n'a pas été
reprise ça a été supprimé enfin ça n'a
pas été défendu ça n'a pas été supprimé
donc il y a beaucoup de collectivités
qui avaient des projets qui n'ont pas pu
être réalisés
donc ça c'est voilà je pense que plus
c'est simple plus c'est efficace plus
les gens s'en saisissent et il faut
alors par rapport à la question que vous
posez sur la fraude
c'est vrai que c'était quelque chose qui
était qui était objectif en terminant
les gens vont frauder et alors c'était
quoi l'idée c'était dire avec le crédit
d'impôt elle dit non mais les gens vont
faire des travaux et de toute façon ils
les auraient fait même sans crédit
d'impôt oui mais alors où est le
problème enfin je veux dire ils font
autre chose du coup s'ils ont un peu
plus d'argent bah ils feront autre chose
ça fera marcher le bâtiment localement
où est le problème donc après c'était
oui mais alors il va y avoir des
trucages parce qu'en fait ils vont
refaire leurs fenêtres ça va coûter un
peu moins cher et en fait il fera en fin
de la pièce et donc du coup ils feront
payer la repenture
écoutez moi alors j'entendais ça dans
les arbitrages interministériel j'ai
écouté moi je on fait pas on met pas en
place d'action politique
en s'occupant des fraudeurs parce que
sinon alors comment est-ce qu'on avance
sans comment ça soupçonner tout le monde
de frauder il vaut mieux une ou deux
bonnes sanctions sur un ou deux fraudeur
et tout le monde sera dissuadé notamment
les entreprises qui pouvaient
éventuellement et encore est-ce que ça
s'est fait je ne sais pas ce qui est en
tout cas vrai c'est que quand vous
faites refaire votre fenêtre vous faites
repeindre la pièce c'est à dire que
c'est un effet d'entraînement sur la
filière bâtiment c'est ça que je disais
c'est pas de la fraude ils font pas
payer ça de toute façon ils dépensent
plus en rembourser pas 100% et c'est
parce que c'était 9000 euros mais dans
une limite donc on ne remboursait jamais
100%, il fallait dépenser beaucoup plus
que plus que 8000 euros je sais plus
combien c'était 50% ou 30%, je me
souviens plus quel était le pourcentage
donc si vous voulez avec
avec un milliard et demi de crédit
d'impôts de déduction fiscale ça fait à
peu près 1 milliard et demi on a généré
moi je pense qu'on a généré 10 fois plus
de travaux on a généré 8 à 10 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires dans les
industries du bâtiment parce que vous
refaites refaire les fenêtres
peindre après vous faites d'isolation
des combles vous voyez après vous
changez votre chaudière enfin il y a de
la cohérence c'est un effet
d'entraînement donc je disais au
ministère des finances mais non le
crédit d'impôt ce qui me dit ça coûte un
milliard et demi mais non ça coûte pas
un milliard et demi ça rapporte puisque
sur les 10 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires les gens vont il y a des
impôts qui vont être payés des
cotisations sociales qui vont être
payées il y a des retours sur
investissement qui vont être payés donc
non
vous injectez vous investissez un
milliard et demi
30%. donc vous voyez 30% ça veut dire
que si vous vouliez être remboursé de
8000 euros il fallait dépenser 24000
euros en travaux sinon vous aviez moins
par exemple vous voyez être rembourse
8000 euros de travaux vous aviez un
tiers de remboursement c'était
raisonnable c'était pas 100% mais du
coup ça a cité les gens à faire plus de
travaux qu'il n'aurait fait et surtout
parmi ces travaux à faire les travaux
d'isolation en premier c'est ça qui est
intéressant parce que si vous voulez
améliorer votre intérieur vous dites bon
j'ai pas les moyens d'isoler les
fenêtres j'ai quand même un bon coup de
peinture je vais acheter des meubles
sympas je vais d'abord penser à ma
qualité de vie alors que si on vous dit
ben non si vous faites en plus isolation
des fenêtres vous êtes remboursé vous
faites isolation des fenêtres donc vous
économisez l'énergie donc vous
économisez du CO2 donc vous participez
aussi à la protection de la planète donc
c'était un cercle vertueux en fait
alors y a-t-il des questions de la part
de nos collègues oui Laurent Burgoa oui
merci Madame la présente merci
madame la ministre pour vous expliquer
par rapport justement au crédit d'impôts
à vous poser un ministre si vous revenez
à des responsabilités est-ce que vous
remettiez le crédit d'impôt lorsque vous
proposerai autre chose qu'on mesure en
matière de politique dans ce domaine là
bien ce crédit d'impôt
tellement de choses à faire crédit
d'impôts et les territoires énergies
positifs c'est tellement efficace et
vous donner un maire les moyens de
d'isoler son école mais il le fait tout
de suite et en plus entretient le tissu
de d'artisans du territoire vous voyez
c'est c'est extraordinaire c'est tout
simple bien sûr j'en mets le crédit
d'impôt l'isolation obligatoire
[Musique]
le calcul individuel des frais de
chauffage mais c'est tellement efficace
c'était le moins efficace quand vous
regardez votre facteur de dos vous
faites attention vous dites tiens
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand ça dépasse
si vous n'avez même pas le compteur de
votre chauffage
si vous vous rendez pas compte de
l'effort que vous faites alors
maintenant on le fait parce que les
enfin moi j'ai toujours fait donc
on se moquait de moi parce que je
sortais de mon bureau de ministre
j'étais ni la lumière
mais personne étant la lumière je dis
bah moi j'étais en lumière j'ai été
éduqué comme ça j'éteins la lumière donc
je donne des instructions chacun éteint
la lumière en sortant du bureau alors
IRI et Souka mais je sais après ils ont
pris l'habitude j'ai dit maintenant
c'est quand même les contribua qui
payent l'énergie vous sortez votre
bureau vous éteignez la lumière
le Président Madame le Ministre avec les
exemples que vous avez cité je pense que
effectivement vous avez dit que vous
aviez reçu des élus des territoires des
maires qui avaient gagné en compétence
en matière écologique et je pense que
l'impact l'effet levier que vous
évoquiez sur un certain nombre de
dispositifs dont vous étiez à l'origine
aujourd'hui on le retrouve à différents
niveaux de collectivité le plaisir et
l'honneur de présider un département
avec 125 collèges par exemple cette
conscience aujourd'hui en matière de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
elle est acquise
alors on continue à faire des collèges
neufs fort heureusement pour pour le
bâtiment mais on a aussi une expertise
sur ceux qui peuvent encore voir leur
durée de de prolonger et améliorer leur
performances énergétique je vous rejoins
aussi sur le fait que aujourd'hui nous
avons
nous avons un voire deux
téléphones très
très lourd en capacité et notamment en
logiciels qui sont téléchargeables et
aujourd'hui on a la possibilité de
télécharger un certain nombre
d'applications c'est le mot que je
cherchais d'application pour le suivi de
nos consommations et donc je pense que
tout cela va peut-être aussi aider nos
concitoyens à avoir une meilleure
gestion de de ces choses là il y a un
sujet qui n'a pas été abordé et moi j'ai
vu l'occasion dans le cadre d'un
programme d'échange européen de suivre
ça c'est sur la géothermie à partir des
eaux d'exorent et il se trouve que nous
avons plusieurs territoires miniers en
France que ce soit dans ou dans le
département du Nord et du Pas-de-Calais
et j'avais vu en Hollande alors le
modèle économique était un peu faussé
parce que c'était expérimental et il
savait bénéficier de de crédits
européens assez conséquent mais la
géothermie à partir des eaux d'exorent
marche notamment sur les équipements
publics sur le logement collectif etc et
pourquoi il y a un frein chez nous à
aller vers la géothermie est-ce que vous
avez une idée par rapport à ça c'est une
énergie que j'ai que j'aime beaucoup la
géothermie voyez elle résolu c'est un
peu comme l'hydroélectricité ces
énergies qui ont résolu le problème de
stockage c'est formidable j'ai ouvert
une usine de géothermie quand j'étais
ministre en Guadeloupe qui était à
l'arrêt puis personne n'y croyait je
pense qu'on a perdu peut-être un des
savoir-faire des ingénieurs qui se sont
peut-être un peu détournés de cette
énergie mais c'est formidable la
géothermie et d'ailleurs à la COP 21 on
a créé une coalition géothermie alors
moi j'étais chef de délégation donc et
il y a le président à ce moment-là de
d'Islande qui vient me voir et qui me
dit la géothermie a géothermie parce que
vous avez le président d'Islande il a
sauvé son pays par la géothermie le pays
était au bord de la faillite et le génie
de se dire maintenant j'ai une terre
volcanique il doit y avoir de l'eau
chaude en dessous ou de la terre chaude
je vais développer mon pays avec la
géothermie et l'Islande a retrouvé une
croissance économique incroyable puisque
vous vous allez en Islande c'est le
premier producteur de bananes quand même
l'Islande par habitant c'est à dire avec
des serres entièrement chauffés à la
géothermie donc l'énergie sauf celle des
voitures et gratuite dans toute l'île
parce qu'il sauvé son pays par la
géothermie donc on a dit bon on fait une
coalition géothermie on était deux on a
lancé un appel à projet toutes les
délégations étrangères et notre grande
surprise on a vu arriver des États
africains l'Éthiopie je me souviens
encore et donc on avait mis en place un
groupe de recherche scientifiques et il
y a des pays qui
ignoraient complètement qu'ils avaient
ce potentiel sous leurs pieds et qui
aujourd'hui sont équipés en géothermie
et donc vous avez parfaitement raison
c'est pas une énergie qui est considérée
comme en haut du haut de la pile si
j'ose dire mais partout il y a de la
géothermie il faut absolument développer
ça ça c'est évident
Laurent saumon
oui merci
j'ai bien compris effectivement vous
êtes plutôt pour une rénovation qui soit
qui puisse être en tout cas parcellaire
et pas forcément globale pour pouvoir
bénéficier de ces aides j'ai compris
aussi que il y avait une importance et
je la partage cette continuité des
politiques en matière de logement pour
avoir effectivement une réussite et
pouvoir constater des résultats vous
avez dit qu'il fallait que ce soit
simple qu'il fallait effectivement
remettre l'avoir fiscale n'est pas parlé
tellement de l'organisation aujourd'hui
on voit avec habiter mieux et la gestion
faite par Lana qui a beaucoup de retard
dans les financements et qui j'allais
dire sinon des gouttes ou en tout cas
fait ralentir peut-être les possibilités
qu'on a qu'est-ce que vous pensez
justement de du rôle de Lana en tout cas
tel qu'il est géré aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de ces rénovations thermiques
indispensables pour améliorer le
développement durable et la protection
des bourses des habitants et également
du climat
pas l'ensemble de la population et par
conséquent si vous voulez à partir du
moment où le crédit d'impôt a disparu
où les gens moyens n'avaient pas non
plus les moyens de faire ne relever à la
fois pas de la NA mais en même temps
n'avait pas les moyens de faire leur
travaux parce qu'il y avait la
disparition du crédit d'impôt ils se
sont tournés vers Lana vous voyez alors
qu'avant l'ANA fonctionnait bien parce
que ceux qui n'avaient pas les moyens
ils savaient que c'était pour eux et les
autres ce qui pouvaient un peu payer et
qui avaient crédit d'impôt ils
insistaient pas pour dire on veut
absolument les l'argent de la nappe
puisqu'on leur dit ben non vous avez le
crédit d'impôt donc essayez d'utiliser
le crédit d'impôt je le répète avec une
ristourne parce que c'est un crédit
d'impôts si vous payez pas d'impôts vous
avez l'équivalent de votre 30% de ce que
vous avez dépensé et donc c'est pour ça
je pense que que la NAR a rencontré
ensuite des difficultés plus j'imagine
des dotations de budgétaire de
fonctionnement
donc il faudrait recentrer la nage je
pense sur les plus défavorisés les plus
modestes et remettre un crédit d'impôts
en contrôlant bien sûr les prix de des
travaux remettez un crédit d'impôt pour
les catégories moyennes et autres alors
après il y a le
il y a les conditions de ressources
c'est un vrai débat ça moi j'avais
refusé les conditions de ressources
parce que je dis le temps perdu la
question du reste à charge peut-être
aussi et la question du reste la charge
donc sur les conditions de ressources
j'avais pas mis de conditions de
ressources parce que j'avais dit ce
qu'il faut c'est développé
les travaux que les gens qui peuvent
payer ils vont avoir leur crédit d'impôt
mais lui c'est le rôle de la fiscalité
d'être juste et ça fait moins de
contrôle parce que comment ça contrôler
qui gagne pas les évolutions perdez des
mois à contrôler le contrôler le les
seuils d'impôts ça crée des effets de
seuil et l'idée que je veux que j'avais
à laquelle j'avais pensé c'est dire plus
il va y avoir de travaux plus les
artisans les entreprises du bâtiment
pourront se développer sur ces
technologies de performance énergétique
des bâtiments et donc en retour tout le
monde en profitera parce que ça fera une
baisse des prix etc alors que si vous
limitez si vous mettez des conditions de
ressources très basses vous vous n'avez
pas un marché suffisamment ambitieux
pour que les entreprises investissent
vous voyez et donc la masse la première
année de la commande sur les travaux
puisque c'est quand même il rien qu'en
rembourse uniquement le remboursement
donc la totalité des travaux comme j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure faisait beaucoup
plus ça crée un marché solvable donc les
entreprises elles peuvent investir elles
peuvent former des gens elles peuvent
correctement les payer elles peuvent
faire attention aux matériaux qu'elles
utilisent etc et puis peut-être qu'après
dans deux trois ans après on aurait pu
mettre une condition de ressources mais
une fois que les choses se serait voyez
bien installés et que ceux qui ont le
plus d'argent qui auraient déjà fait
leurs travaux à ce moment-là ils
arrivent à un seuil et du coup on aurait
pu concentrer les investissements sur
les autres catégories mais pas tout de
suite parce qu'il fallait créer un
marché
c'était ça le raisonnement
tu le rapporteur
sur ce que vous disiez sur effectivement
sur la question du reste à charge
je l'entends mais ce qu'on s'aperçoit
aussi c'est que sur les foyers les plus
précaires en fait
le reste à charge c'est ce qui bloque
justement parce que quand même si on a
un crédit d'impôt maintenant ma prime
rénov etc il reste quand même et même si
c'est un crédit taux zéro etc il reste
quand même quelque chose et souvent qui
est bloquant pour les personnes avec les
plus faibles revenus quoi et donc du
coup la question justement du reste à
charge zéro il se pose quand même là du
coup pour les plus les plus bas revenus
donc je sais pas si c'est quelque chose
sur lequel vous aviez pu
réfléchir ouais c'est l'intervention
c'est Lana qui peut prendre le reste à
charge dès lors que les autres ont un
crédit d'impôt vous concentrez le rôle
de l'agence nationale l'amélioration de
l'habitat sur la prise en charge du
reste à charge et même sur l'avance des
fonds des travaux
par ailleurs c'est les propriétaires
donc si vous êtes modeste et que vous
êtes propriétaire déjà vous êtes
propriétaire elle a intervient donc à
intervient directement pour vous si vous
êtes propriétaire et que vous louez à
quelqu'un de modeste c'est plus souvent
ça et qu'en plus vous louez une passoire
thermique
Lana elle intervient mais elle valorise
le bien du propriétaire qui est pas
forcément lui dans une situation modeste
vous voyez ce que je veux dire donc le
nombre de gens très modestes qui en plus
sont propriétaires et qui n'ont pas les
moyens de faire les travaux c'est quand
même relativement restreint et donc cela
vous avez raison la nappe prendre en
charge la totalité des travaux
merci
un présidente madame la ministre moi je
me demandais que pensez-vous de
l'installation sur les toits plats
de panneaux solaires notamment pour tout
ce qui est les logements HLM souvent on
a des
logements en tout cas dans le sud
puisque comme vous le voyez avec mon
accent
voilà et est-ce que vous avez une idée
de la production que cela pourrait
représenter au total en France dans
l'atteinte de notre autonomie
énergétique est-ce qu'il y a eu un
calcul est-ce que ça a été étudié ça
c'est tous les trois étaient équipés
l'étoile et là on produit à peu près en
énergie renouvelable l'équivalent de 6
réacteurs nucléaires depuis la montée en
puissance tout compris sauf
l'hydroélectricité l'éolien etc donc je
pense que c'est quand même un ou deux
réacteurs nucléaires faciles
l'équipement en énergie après vous avez
deux de mécanisme soit en
autoconsommation vous mettez vos
panneaux vous éclairer etc
d'autoconsommation soit vous renvoyer
vers le réseau et à ce moment-là vous
êtes remboursé de ce que vous revendez
sur le réseau c'est souvent comme ça que
font les les bâtiments collectifs
puisque du coup ça diminue aussi les
charges énergétiques de l'ensemble des
habitants de l'immeuble mais vous avez
raison
non seulement si ça ça avait c'est pour
ça que quand j'ai dit quand je disais on
va rendre tous les bâtis tous les
nouveaux bâtiments obligatoires énergies
positive alors ça faisait une révolution
ça faisait un saut technologique moi je
pense que dans un certain moment de
l'histoire oui il faut faire un saut
technologique comme quand on est passé
du téléphone à au portable il y a bien
eu un saut technologique donc dans
l'énergie il y a un saut il y a un saut
technologique une révolution à faire
pour dire bah oui d'accord allez à
partir de la semaine prochaine tous les
permis devront être à énergie positif un
moment faut bien faut bien se lancer
est-ce que vous dites serait juste on
dirait ben écoutez tous les trois qui
peuvent être équipés en énergie solaire
dans les régions ensoleillées allez il
faut tous le faire mais vous savez on
pourrait commencer par les aéroports
combien de fois j'ai parlé au président
d'Aéroport de Paris
faites des centrales solaires sur vos
toits toutes les grandes surfaces tous
les carrefours tout ça ça devrait être
obligatoire
les centrales solaires surtout les toits
partout et la récupération d'eau de
pluie partout
voyez c'est mais dès qu'on met une
contrainte aux gens ils renaquent même
quand c'est leur intérêt parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils auraient fait les
travaux ça coûtait moins cher
qu'aujourd'hui déjà le prix des travaux
a augmenté mais ils auraient fait des
économies d'énergie
donc faut une dernière question comment
est-ce que vous jugez aujourd'hui la
politique est conduite dans le domaine
de la rénovation énergétique plus
particulièrement puisque ce qui nous
intéresse
il y a des petites choses qui sont
faites et la prime
rénovir c'est pas la hauteur de pourquoi
détruire pourquoi casser ce qui marche
voyez on pourrait dire dans plein de
domaines pourquoi abîmer ce qui marche
ça appartient pas au ministres en
exercice appartient à la nation ça c'est
des choses sont faites et devrait y
avoir impossibilité
c'est une réflexion peut-être pour le
Sénat qui aurait pas avoir un droit de
veto en disant la voix là vous régressez
vous le principe de non régression en
plus c'est inscrit dans la loi le
principe de non régressions et je me
souviens quand Nicolas Hulot disait bah
parce que je l'appelais je lui dis mais
comment est-ce que comment est-ce que
vous avez pu laisser supprimer tout ça
bah je sais pas je sais pas c'est les
arbitrages sinon c'est bien non principe
de non régression mais vous allez à une
réunion et vous ne sait tout le principe
de non-régressions non on regrette pas
c'est ça qui permet de tenir c'est les
principes il leur dit non principe
principe de non régression on ne recule
pas mais ça devrait être un peu dans
tous les domaines oui même pour le
législateur parce que c'est dispositifs
ils ont été votés à l'unanimité de
l'assemblée du Sénat donc à un moment
quand ça revient et que ça recule il
devrait y avoir quelque chose une
commune ou en commission je ne sais pas
où on dit bah non expliquez-nous
pourquoi il y a pourquoi il y a une
régression non non régression
vous vous posez la question de la
durabilité alors du d'une mesure où
d'une loi c'est ça voudrait dire qu'on
pourrait pas avant un certain nombre
d'années pour je comprends pas bien le
comment on pourrait arriver à ça dans un
dans un pays où
l'alternance démocratique fait partie de
la règle du jeu en quelque sorte du jeu
politique j'entends oui c'est une bonne
question
puisqu'on est sur du développement
durable vous voulez que les lois qui
sont
affectées au développement durable
bénéficient d'une durabilité dans le
temps à laquelle on ne puisse pas qu'on
ne puisse pas écourter
déjà dans la loi la non régression est
inscrite dans la loi vous voyez empêcher
réduire compenser non régression c'est
c'est dans les fondements même de la
transition énergétique et à partir du
moment on a l'accord de Paris sur le
climat il s'impose à tous l'accord de
Paris sur le climat donc quand vous avez
des politiques qui vont dans le sens de
l'accord de Paris sur le climat il
devrait pas être possible de reculer
merci